put your hand down if you've never done
a cocaine if you've never done it yeah
what you make them do without me ask you
you've done that you liar crack cow
[Music]
so cocaine has been synthesized in a
tobacco plant
wow that's good news that's illegal how
here we go
like the real theaters like the theaters
oh like Regal Theaters yeah
the the we're on the popcorn roller
coaster and they're popping and there's
vines coming out
[__] pager from like 1990.
silence your cell phone yeah you don't
like Regal no I hate it what do you like
do you like the UA
United Artists I'm an edge Loops guy
dude
I'm a Krikorian class
I pick her nothing okay I do like I pick
I do like I'm a snobby Ark like boy Elmo
Drafthouse I've never been I think you'd
like it I would love it I think is it
better than I picked yeah it's like a
cool it's like a cooler I pick how is it
I pick is pretty fun yeah but I pick is
like Tech it's like very like uh
structural and then Alamo is like it has
the illusion of being like down to earth
and very like chill but it's still very
strict about not [__] around during
the movie and you can still buy a
sandwich just still there's a bar
there's a full bar right yeah it's it's
like uh yes do they have servers yeah do
they have the reclining chairs do those
chairs that I pick are but it's more
like it's like if hipsters butt I pick
oh hey Bart this is not a disc
just know that when you go to a movie
you have to go like 5 30 so you don't
fall asleep
honestly if someone invites me to watch
a movie past eight I have to politely
decline somebody said he would fall
asleep I remember want to catch a
matinee bar and it looks like this I
swear to God the sun's going down with
the credits I will not
so if I'm like oh I've seen this movie
before I'm like sure let's go so you got
matinees only save money what's matinees
thinking today what the [__] what's
matinee I don't even speak normal
English is like this guy Joe you made a
business with this guy we're on YouTube
okay that's why we don't have a film
okay okay what's matinee
Bart's like my dream is like writing a
film and producing a movie he's like
what's matinee by the way
that's very correct okay so a team of
resources at the Chinese what's the
screening working with a colleague from
uh the UK have developed a way to
synthesize cocaine using a tobacco plant
whoa finally so synthesized so now they
can smoke crack growing cocoa coca
plants to produce cocaine you know it's
like a big intensive project scientists
have been looking for a way to produce
it in a lab but all these efforts have
not been have not seen progress because
um those complex biochemistry in the
cocoa plant and it's valuable byproduct
obviously so now in this new effort
researchers have not only figured out
the biochemistry of the plant and the
cocaine it produces have synthesized
small amounts of cocaine by genetically
engineering a type of tobacco plant to
just make it in its leaves
somebody in that lab is getting a call
from a guy saying are you trying to cut
out the Colombians oh
and then it's it's they're Chinese
scientists right they go [__] you guy
[__] you man [__] you man we met covert
man we [__] you okay
I'm not scared at you I saw Knuckles
already that he's dead and it was boring
after that it was boring Mexico was
terrible time for the Pablo Esco Chang
oh that's good
so so people might be wondering why are
they they doing this like are they just
trying to make cocaine yeah or make
better cocaine so they say that this is
a size
man so they say that they're doing this
um to produce it for use in medical
applications oh yes of course the
medical applications control of course
let's do a bump in the ICU or something
for pain brother I think they don't they
still use codeine or something or
codeine well no they use because it's
very different from cocaine they use uh
uh the other one the one the [__]
Civil War One Morphine Morphine
that is hot right now yeah at the
hospital opiate though it's more from
the heroin yeah morphine works pretty
good unless you have kidney stones yeah
that's the one thing beneath they put
really put it into you and you still
felt it yeah really that's what I mean
to me like people good lucky like
everyone I saw that whole Christmas okay
you got morphine lucky and I'm like bro
I'm in actual pain I'm not like [__]
chilling there like oh this is so sick
so if they gassed you to sleep would you
still be going oh
honestly
try to work here Steve
you laugh that's my pain but yes yes
did you watch your dick the whole time
do they watch my dick the whole time I
was I was passed out you were they put
you to sleep the doctor saw your penis
and they're like good for him though
titty Stones pretty bad that was the
last thing I remember
hey let's go
good for you request a lady doctor I did
because I didn't want to be seen this
game
he didn't want that show up at his chart
yeah because I know Steve he's like no
way am I gonna wake up [__] lasts
forever dude if it's on the chart if
people know man you're like
scientifically gay well because when I
was with my father-in-law um like
medically again and then he was like
he's like let's go have a beer outside
so I was like okay and so we're sitting
down and he's like he's like so um
you know did did a guy doctor
um do your surgery
and then I'm like
he's like that would mean you're gay
right what no no they're my daughter but
these are gay though you let another man
touch your privates like that what kind
of man are you what do you get yourself
and you're like no no no no no no no Dad
it was a surgery yeah but I I I
specifically asked for a female surgeon
and he goes okay cool yeah and then he's
like
so did she suck it no was she hot is she
a babe that's pretty crazy that morphine
couldn't keep that from hurting I know
one can stop it what's better than death
nothing it was so bad though because
they always assume you're a drug addict
like if you're if you want pain meds
they just assume you're a drug addict
immediately especially in Vegas by the
way oh really Vegas is actually I mean
it's a great place to live I bet there's
a lot of drug addicts too though but
well that's the worst dude L.A doesn't
have any yeah that's crazy they treat
you more like you're a drug addict in
Vegas yeah and so like if you're just
trying to get like you know like Nikki
just wants to get
um her Adderall or whatever and they're
like you're a [__] drug addict it's
like you gotta say that like you gotta
do all that well they're basically you
gotta take a urine test to prove that
you have it in your system and you're
not selling it because that's what
that's all they care about could uh I
could fix your problem
you got a guy
um my college roommate owns a pharmacy
in Vegas
allegedly we don't want to do this on
camera now do we oh well no it's fine
because because we because we're still
getting all serious no it's fine Joe
because what we do at home is we just we
just actually crush it all up and we
snort it yeah and I do have a big box of
uh good stuff that people left over for
me perfect like what's in the box you
just went from being careful to just
being completely on the same
I'm possessing we're gonna go there what
we're gonna do is we're gonna buy a
plane right we have this box of drawers
the good thing is those things are not
illegal substances so I don't need to
take it on I don't need to transfer it
into a plane you don't need to sell a
plane
because they're not illegal all you do
is put it into like liquid form you you
make it wet and you start pasting it on
the walls of the plane
wallpaper in the plane and they're like
oh
nice
oh cool nice stuff
I think the appraiser missing
it and then you cover the whole plane
with it it's all Sig narcotics theme I
really like this striped wallpapers
yep
and when you land packaging tape Martha
Stewart collection
so you have to sell the plane that's
good that's really good Joe uh everyone
can you guys raise your hands does
everyone raise your hands you too yeah
uh
put your hand down if you've never done
cocaine if you've never done it yeah if
you put your hands once you make him do
it let me ask you you've done it you
liar those crack count
I don't know but you have something like
that no because I was gonna ask like uh
what's it like it's not the same no no
because it's not the same
Coke is like
another visual cue to see you Anthony
can tell you what it's like without
having to tell you he's done it
all right put your hand your hands down
if a male doctor's ever touch your dick
put your hand down if he has yeah oh
dude of course if he has to oh you guys
are so good it's like you guys are wrong
wait has he we wouldn't you want a real
doctor working on it don't you I don't
know I've had a woman doctor touch my
penis and that was really embarrassing I
liked it
hahaha
I liked it why why why yeah why'd you
like it
is it because she had to it's just kind
of a gilf
Michelle yeah no it was uh it was at a
uh a military Hospital
and she was touching all the guys she's
a military doctor and I had to do my
annual checkup and she was all up in her
uniform and [__] yeah so it felt like
you know how like in GI Jane like all
the dudes were discriminating against
the girl I felt like all the girls were
discriminating against me but I'm here
to prove something and then she'd grab
my my little nuts four figure saluting
the whole time and I was here to prove
something that you grabbed my little
nuts oh she's checking you yeah and
you're like did you hear the call of a
bald eagle
yeah did you get hard now I was really
nervous my dick got shriveled up me too
yeah I thought it was cool when I was a
kid and I got measured by a female
seamstress at Friar Tux you're like whoa
whoa because you have to get really
close to your inner thigh when they do
it I need to find out your inseam yeah
oh [__] and your waist and you're like
put your arms up they do that they do
that for sure
[Music]